now thousands of people are set to ring
bells on their doorsteps this
christmas eve to help spread unity and
combat loneliness more than
445 000 people have signed up to the
campaign
it was started started by mary begs reed
will sky's gerard tubbers in harrogate
with mary gerard
and this is where it started um a quiet
part of harrogate the idea
initially was that people in this area
would come out on their doorsteps and
ring bells remember clap for carers
beginning of the first national lockdown
turned into millions of people across
the country
joining in um well the idea was
something along those lines but then it
grew like topsy it's now been
adopted by the national organization
together um they're publicizing it on
their website and just like clap for
care as it's now become
political the prime minister's going to
get involved the department for health
ended up
promoting clap for carers quite whether
it'll get to that stage or not we don't
know mary is with me
the you had the initial idea and today i
know this doesn't normally happen to you
but you had a
phone call with a prime minister today
yes yeah with the prime minister and
carrie
um which was wonderful and so unexpected
but yeah he's uh
he's really up for doing it i said that
carrie him and the baby
will be on the steps of number 10
ringing the bells at 6 p.m with
hopefully so many more of us this is on
christmas eve
christmas eve 6 p.m for two minutes the
ringing of bells
so what did it mean to you you had this
idea back in october and now it's been
taken on by a national organization
and it's happening all over the place
isn't it oh yeah all over the world it's
so
moving it's going to sound wonderful and
it'll be a wave of bells across the
world on christmas eve and
just so that we can feel a little bit of
magic help santa flies slay and we're
connected for two minutes
even though not physically we can ring
bells together at least
so what's it going to mean to people do
you think you persuaded people around
here to put up posters in their windows
what was the initial idea of what you
were going to achieve
just really for community spirit keep us
together
and just spread a little bit of magic
and for the children especially because
they've had a really tough year
so i wanted to do something for them
really for two minutes
to raise christmas spirit and have a
little bit of magic on christmas and to
look forward to something again
mary that's brilliant you look very
festive with your santa hat
on um just before we head back to the
studio give us an idea
of what it's going to sound like on
christmas eve take it away